oh hello everyone hello hello hello let me fix this up real
quick oh my gosh i don't know why i'm so oh i know why i i
was like i don't know why guys i don't know why i'm so eepy
i say as i went to bed last night at six in the morning
point okay yes okay i was gonna say was it six this time
yeah six in the morning playing deadlock oh i don't know why
why am i so tired oh what could it possibly bleed i guess
i'll never know oh i guess i'll never know why i'm so tired
it's it truly is a mystery oh I almost I almost got myself
you know I almost lied I was lied to my gaslighted myself be
like guys man I'm so confused I feel like I tried everything
and I'm still so tired I almost gaslighted myself into
thinking I'm thinking I just don't know, I guess.
All right, let me fix this real quick.
All right, zoom in a little bit.
Let's see.
Move myself around real quick.
I realize, oh, my God, my immersion.
I need to be, like, right here.
Actually, I don't know.
I should be, like, closer.
Maybe, like, here.
I don't know.
Yeah, this would be good.
fuck it I'll be here actually am I centered I think so all
right hello everyone hello hello um no sorry sorry for the
immersion I just don't like you I'm not centered uh you
don't have ADHD I'm just I just don't like it when I'm not
centered on the screen it just just when it's like you know
when you're hanging some a painting and you're just like
you're something off about why is it not why is it not it
has to be pixel perfect yes exactly um also let me Hold.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello, guys.
I'm sorry.
I, oh my gosh.
Okay.
If you guys don't follow me on, on Twitter, I have a
problem.
I have a, I have a problem.
Okay.
To be fair, like, it's only REM.
It's only when it's REM.
Like, I, I, okay, I have a deadlock problem right now.
So, you know how, like, in time?
Um, okay.
I don't have OC.
I may actually have OCD.
Or I know I'm a perfectionist.
I actually, I'm not, I don't have, like, like, I think I'm
high functioning OC.
I have high I always have this problem.
This is a gaming problem for me.
But basically, whenever...
I don't know.
I just like to see numbers go up.
I just...
I don't deserve to be fruit fly at Elo.
I knew it.
I fucking know I don't deserve to be in fruit fly at Elo.
I...
I don't deserve to be there with those people.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry if you are I'm sorry if you are in Ratlow I but no
you don't understand you don't they're not some of these
people in that rank is they're not real they're not fucking
real I refuse to believe that they wake up every day as
fully functioning human beings in a queue up rank I refuse
to believe that that it's like an AI they must be like an AI
or something that deadlocked in places just so because
there's not enough people in that elo so they have like ai
they're playing as there's no other explanation there's no
other fucking explanation um i quote thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you hi dokey i'm retaking okay i'm just
finished my first lab it's going better than last year hope
it stays that way good luck over thank you thank you for the
super chat quote thank you thank you um uh but good luck
good luck i hope you do well all right let me i just
realized i forgot to pull out the super chat tab so let me
get that out as well guys uh yeah and honestly no i think i
think i think i would rather have a fruit fly because at
least i know like who i'm playing like what who i have as a
teammate like
I don't know.
It's just a game.
It's just a gamer in me.
I just, I, I just, I don't, I don't want to, I don't want to
be in that rank anymore.
I just don't give me out.
Nobody's thinking of the gift ship.
Thank you.
I know you've been busy.
So no worries.
I haven't seen my emails yet.
I'd love to.
Oh, okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Car wash.
Thank you.
Um, anyway, uh, okay.
I need to remember.
Sorry.
to read it in my head first before I read anything out loud
to that one person I hope you know you're saying those
emails to my manager and not to me I so my manager has read
every email um um anyway As I was saying, what was I saying?
Oh, my gosh.
What was that?
I lost my train.
That caught me off guard.
I did not think they would super chat.
I...
All right.
I was like, oh, my God.
I did not think that was ever going to happen.
I know exactly what emails they're talking about, too,
because my manager has told me about those emails.
I don't...
exactly what the emails are and i've been done i didn't
realize they would show themselves into my stream i so it
caught me i was like oh my it's you oh my god
really no no no um cyber thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you honest question why is your rank so important
it feels like all it does just suck the fun out of the game
put undue pressure on you they give us super chat they could
thank you because it makes me feel good.
I just like, I think it's an ego thing for me.
I will say it's an ego thing.
And basically, I just like seeing being, I like seeing
myself improve and being good at a game.
So because I've always, I think the worst part about
Deadlock is that I've never placed in such a low rank before
like so it's like i'm just like i need to prove myself you
know being like because i like being i like improving and
being good at a game that i put my like actually um when i
like that actually like uh putting my effort into to
learning it so like if it's a game that i don't really care
too much then um then whatever like i valerine i don't
fucking care about valerine care what rank i am getting in
there because i don't find that game fun for deadlock i like
rem And I like to see myself improve as Rem.
I don't fucking care about any other character.
If I get any other character, I would literally just coast.
Like, I don't care.
Like, I'll try.
But obviously, it won't be, like, me trying on a character
that's not Rem.
Obviously, it's not the same performance as me trying on
Rem.
Because I put all my skill points on Rem alone.
So, yeah.
And then, so, basically.
I just like seeing my numbers go up and I like being good at
a game.
You know, I like being like, I like being like decent at it.
Not, you know, not like the best at it.
And also, I don't know if I'll ever hit top 500 deadlock,
but I do like seeing how much I've improved and improving.
It's like adrenaline, you know?
It's like an adrenaline for me.
And I just like being good at it because I've never been
this low rank before, too.
That's what's like been putting me in a chokehold right now.
making me play deadlock like every day for hours at night
because I'm just like I just I don't I I can't I'm sorry I
know I'm always like I'm for the people you know I'm but
these are one of those moments where I cannot be for the
people we cannot be at the same level I'm sorry these are
one of those moments where we cannot be the same not in
ratlo guys not in ratlo and like i don't want to i got like
so high oh my gosh i can't they're not real these i can't
guys these are one of those moments I have I need to be
hiring I just can't I I'll settle for plat just not rat bro
just not that's like just just not rat I'll settle for plat
guys I actually I'm trying to get plat right now because at
least I can be plat Chad but not rat low bro no no no that's
that i don't want to say but no no that's i'm sorry but
it's just i don't please do not compare me to people in that
rank please for the love of god i don't put me in with the
fruit flies um but i think i know i'm getting better i've
been getting um the last few days of playing i'm sort of
it's sort of been clicking more and then i've been getting
i'm still really like it's my first moba too i think the
biggest reasons why i play so low is because um it's my
first moba game and so i've never i don't know i don't know
how to lane i don't know how to rotate like we're going in i
didn't really know how to lane i didn't really know how to
rotate i didn't really know how to like when to get cams
when to get like i been getting better and better at like uh
uh figuring that out um and i think i'm i think i've been
proving and getting mvps the last couple of days the last
three the last three days i've been getting mvp mvp
consistently and getting really high damage numbers on rem
um i will say okay i don't think i've have i told you guys i
told you guys yeah i was uh um i went to five i think i went
yeah two six on my placements i don't think i've told you
guys but remember when i said like i one uh and it was like
one four one five or whatever or one yeah one four one five
um or something uh because i kept getting troll throwers and
dcers so after that day i you know i finished my placements
and then i got i okay one of the games was crazy because i
had someone dc in the middle of the game and then they came
back 10 minutes like i think like uh they came we were safe
to leave and then when they came and then and then you know
it was already too late because um he was already behind in
souls and uh you know uh they like the enemy team won every
team fight because it was a five like it was a 5v6 and then
um the worst part is another player left uh four minutes
before the game was supposed to end so the fact that he left
four minutes before the game ended ended fucked us over
because if the guy left and five minutes passed then the
loss will be count like the loss um will be like negated so
it won't be added into your uh rankings so the most fucked
up part was the guy left four minutes before the game ended
so we couldn't get the the free like the the get out of jail
free card and i'm like in the same game so two different
people left the game that fucked me over and then i got a
thrower on my second game i got a thrower on my second game
as well and then so my only had two games in my placements
where nobody threw and we had an actual real game like it
was great like two games two two out of eight games my they
weren't thrown and then we had a real game so i was able to
win anyway i started learning rave i started learning rave
because i felt like i can't play rave it's either i do it's
either i have to do with someone that would shoot their gun
or or i learned rape so i've been trying to learn rape too
on the side in that elo because i feel like if i have to get
out of that rank i have to shoot my gun like that's the only
way it's literally the only fucking way it's yeah so i've
been trying all the worst first I need 15 worms I only have
one I it's like oh my god get me out of get me out of this
rink get me out I don't oh my god I don't want to be in this
rink anymore it only took me three days it took me three
days and I was like I get me out I can't do this anymore I
can't fucking I fucking can't So So I have a problem right
now I I have a problem At the I did rank up though I have a
four game win streak right now So I'm Rack 2 Guys I went
from Rack 1 To Rack 2 Just four more to go there's more of a
rats to go and then I could be frog rank and then I could be
a frog yay higher rat I'm climbing my way out of there the
rat grows getting bigger step by step oh anyway back to
let's see Uh, where was that?
I'm sorry, that got me.
If you talk about deadlock, it'll be like an hour
conversation about the game.
Try League of Law.
I'm not that depressed.
I'm depressed, but not that depressed.
Fudge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, look, I don't hate myself that much, Fudge.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank.
I, no, I legitimately hate everything about MOBAs.
hate all like in terms of like mechanically playing i like i
don't mind watching mobas but playing wise i hate everything
it is to do about playing a moba game because i don't really
i don't like farming i don't like farming i don't like um i
don't like uh going through lanes i don't like uh i just
don't like farming guys i i just don't like doing camps i
think it's so boring i i just want to throw my pillows on
things and and then get kills the adrenaline when you get a
kill and win a team fight that's what gets me that's what
gets me going in deadlock it makes me click queue again and
also rem um but league is like i just want to shoot things i
don't i also like i don't i like the only clicking thing
game i like to play other than cow clicker is like rts stuff
so like I don't really care much about I don't know it's
just the gameplay loop is not for me when it comes to like I
don't really like TFT I don't really like uh what like uh
there's too much thinking it's too much thinking involved I
think that's what I I play video games to not think you know
I'm already thinking a lot outside I overthink a lot outside
of gaming so like I just don't want to think even more like
I'm a left to right I'm I'm still left to right guys the
only thing I I learned another thing if someone is playing
haze you buy the metal skin or whatever the fuck it is if
someone plays apollo i play by slowing hex if someone plays
anything to do with uh guy who floats in the air ults or
like in the sky i buy knockdown that's that's all the
counter buying i'm doing i i left to right like that's
that's the extent of my counter buy if someone tells me I
But I don't like to I don't know I just don't like games
that require too much thinking Like I think RTS is a little
Okay I know like but Doki The whole thing about RTS is that
it means Real time strategy The thing for me for RTS games
It's because I grew up playing RTS games I grew up playing
Heroes of Might of Magic So like for me Like those types of
games It's like already like muscle memory for me.
And it's like, I don't have to actually learn it because I
already grew up with those games growing up.
So it's more so I just like click on like I just like, oh, I
remember how to do this.
I just click on this and then go there and it's just
instinct at that point.
It's like second nature.
But then, but then if you put me like in like games I'm not
familiar with like MOBAs in general, then I'm just like, I'm
like, I don't want to.
reading like because like i already know what the gate like
because i said i played starcraft before i played like
here's my magic i don't really need to read it because i
already read it before growing up like pastoki came in
clutch and read it already read it in advance for me so so i
don't have to i don't have to reread it like i already know
what they do like through like from my memories of pastoki
uh Instinctively know how it works Um Aphelion, thank you
for super chat Thank you, thank you That's already more
counter-binding than good chunk of the player base Thank you
for the super chat Thank you, thank you Um, but yeah Like, I
don't know I just Like, I Mova is not like my Not really my
genre But because like Deadlock is a hybrid Mova Where it's
like It has like shooting mechanics Like pew pew mechanics
and everything Like that's where I click with it Like and
then I've like learn to oh and i love stealing sinners i
just love being that little rat like i'll be like i'm gonna
go for it i'm gonna go for it i don't know it's just the
adrenaline of being a little a little shit is walking up
because i know i know that they're pissed off too you know
like you know when you're like for rem and you're stealing
their sinners like the the satisfaction that i know the
enemy team is so fucking mad that took their oh man that
that's like that gets me going like that's that's the treat
for me it's it's what like fuels me
um so that's also why i've been enjoying like i like i said
it's like the little things like that's why i've been
enjoying grim but i don't think like and then when i play
any other I have to do the sinners myself.
I was like, oh my gosh, I'm such a peasant.
I'm such a little, I'm such I'm not even a little chud
anymore.
I'm such a big fat chud.
I have to do my own sinners.
I have to gamble myself.
Yeah, I was like, I can't just click a button and it works
wrong.
I got to sit there and fucking punch a fucking slap.
I'm just like, I'm like, why can't I have, why can't I have
my little helpers do it for me?
No, why did my family went bankrupt and now to do everything
myself?
Yeah, I'm like, don't you wish I had to do any, I have to
use my own hands.
Oh, oh my god, what do you mean I have to use my own?
hands um anyway but yeah that's been uh my that's been my
adventures with deadlock but I oh my gosh that's what I'm
saying I'm having a I have a problem right now because I
have like like I said you guys are so lucky you didn't live
through my apex addiction um deadlock right now okay I was
tempted to stream deadlock today I was legitimately but I
was like I shouldn't do that to them I shouldn't I shouldn't
do that again like I've grown as a person You know like I
shouldn't I shouldn't pull what I did for arrivals Because I
was this tempted where I was like this week would have been
two deadlock I would put two deadlock streams today and
Saturday and I was just like oh Do I I stopped myself.
I was about to put deadlock on Saturday But I was like no, I
shouldn't do this to them.
I can't put them through my my right my rival's addiction
I I stopped myself um you know bring back the marvel rivals
rank days where i stopped my entire streams just for rivals
and not all it was was just rivals until i got top 500 um
unfortunately no one i asked my friends i was like you think
i can't i have what it takes to take to be eternist and then
one of my friends was like wake up the accident wasn't here
but my friends It was like, it was like, wake up, you're in
a coma.
And another one.
And I had my friend.
Um, was, I was like, it was like maybe in 20 years when
Tedlock 3 comes out.
I was like, you guys don't believe in me.
And they're like, well, it's not that we don't believe in
you.
It's that we don't believe in us.
And then I think Ben was like, was like, Doki, even Sherifor
is an intern.
It's like, what the fuck are you on about?
Like, I was like, yeah, but like, I'm like, yeah, but if I
work really hard, maybe I'll learn.
And he's like, bro, even Sherifor is not even intern.
Like, you know how many hours he has in that game?
Like, yeah.
But...
That's, uh, I think like, I think, I, okay, I don't think I
can reach top 500.
I think I would be very happy.
I think if I was make a, if I were to make a goal, a goal,
it'd be like Phantom.
I think that would, even that's sort of reaching it.
That's, that's sort of, uh, that's sort of reaching it even
then, like, pushing about my boundaries would be phantom um
but like honestly i'm climbing at a decent rate right now
yeah that's i'm climbing at a decent rank um a decent rate
right now and we'll see where it goes but like i said that's
what i'm saying i'm having i have a problem i i'm trying my
best to what's the word to like not have it take a hold of
me in terms of streaming wise i'm trying really hard right
now I, I, like, what's the word?
I, like, stopping myself.
There's a word for it.
I, I resisted the temptation, guys.
I, it called for me today.
It, it called.
I was in bed.
I woke.
I was like, why don't you play deadlock?
It was like a green goblin mask.
I had, I had self-control.
It was, the deadlock was, like, calling me, like, I had
restraint, guys.
I, I, it was calling me, like, a green goblin.
in mass.
It's like, you do it, do it, Doki.
Don't you want to stream more deadlock?
It doesn't kill your channel, Doki.
Kill your channel for deadlock.
Yes, yes.
I was like, I could.
I could.
You're so right.
I could kill my channel for the next month.
And then all I do is just stream deadlock Anonibusha.
I could do it.
Like, no, don't fall.
Don't fall for it, Doki.
Don't.
Don't, that's what it wants.
Yeah, it's just Rem be like, do it, do it, Doki.
You know you wanna play me.
You know you wanna play Rem, right?
Oh my god, I do, I do wanna play Rem right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Dookie!
So, I feel I'd like to congratulate myself for having
self-control and resisting the temptation and restraining
myself from putting three more streams of Deadlock today and
also try I could have streamed Deadlock today.
I could have.
I stopped myself.
and uh uh but no i have a problem right now i really i
really do have a problem like i said whenever i get like
addicted to i don't even say addicted to a game i'm addicted
to rem uh all i want to do is just play that game i don't
want to do anything else i just want to play that specific
game until I get into get to a rank that I'm satisfied with
it has happened with Overwatch it has happened with Apex you
guys have seen it happen with uh rivals and also with
Overwatch 2 and now now oh my god I don't remember if you
guys remember Overwatch 2 where I all I did was like play
Overwatch 2 for hours and hours until I got top 500 It is a
recurring pattern whenever there is a game that just gets a
hold of me.
And this is the first time I'm trying.
Yes, I'm trying so hard to resist the temptations right now.
It's calling for me.
I hear Rem's voice in my head right now.
I hear it and he's like, come on.
dokey boot up deadlock right now don't you want to get out
of rat rails i do i really do i i say this drawing dokey oh
my god quick someone tied me to the bed i'm gonna turn i'm
gonna like quick someone restraining me from the bed before
i turn I it's like I'm a fucking werewolf like REM wolf a
wear wear rem I guess
she's turning um yeah me thank you for the super chat thank
you hop on deadlock Jakarta thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you deadlock doki is doki's villain persona
whispering are you in or are you up you're the one that's
out deadlock doki out of your mind thank you Super chat,
thank you, thank you.
All right, okay, so anyway, okay, so I have been running
away from my responsibilities.
Anyway, this has been a long tangent to say that I have been
running away from my responsibilities.
Okay, to be fair, it's even worse the fact that I'm solo
Ely.
Like, that makes it even worse for me, because it's like, oh
my God, it's like my egos.
I feel, I'm...
I was like, I don't belong here.
I just don't belong here.
Get me out.
I want to get out as fast as I can.
Guys, you don't understand.
I need to get out of that, Elo, as fast as I can.
I can't be there.
I cannot.
I...
All right.
Sorry.
Okay.
I'm calming down.
Every day I'm...
The longer I'm stuck in Ratlow.
The more I lose myself.
Like, TikTok.
Oh, listen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Speaking of bad habits, I won a Gamma today.
Which means we both won a Gamma.
Yippee!
Oh, listen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, anyway, sorry.
But I have, so this tangent is going to lead me to the point
where, to the other topic I want to talk about, which is
I've been using deadlock to run to, you know, gaming is my
escapism.
So I have been using deadlock to run away from my
responsibilities and my work, which is not great.
It's not good, and I know this.
The first step is admitting you have a problem.
But, Doki, how many times have you admitted you have?
No, no, first step.
This is my first step, you guys.
A very, my very first step is admitting that I have a
problem.
And I acknowledge that I have a problem.
And I'm improving myself.
Exactly, Husky.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The problem, the pattern has always been there since way
back when you admitted.
you stop streaming for months when ranked apex was your
addiction we already know what you are it wasn't just apex
it was also overwatch as well um it was overwatch and apex
and but the thing is i am getting better you know like i
don't disappear for months and weeks playing ranky anymore
um i mean even in overwatch yes i might have canceled
streams i might have changed streams for overwatch or rivals
but this time i might have played rivals when i was supposed
to stream something else um but this time i might have made
an entire week dedicated to rivals rank and this like lived
on twitch for a while uh until i got top 500 in rivals but
this time and i might have also like slept that like might
have not slept until like 11 a.m playing rank for rivals and
This time, this time, I have yet to cancel a stream or
change a stream for Deadlock, guys.
I haven't done that yet, but that doesn't mean I will do
that for Deadlock.
It doesn't mean that, guys.
It's just I didn't do it.
I didn't do it this time.
And also, and also, I didn't play Deadlock Rank till 11 a.m.
because I just unlocked rank, uh, yesterday.
So...
Who the fuck's gonna play standard until 11 a.m.
Um, anyway.
So...
But...
This time...
This time, I'm...
I'm stronger than I was before.
I'm a stronger version of Doki.
And I've...
I've yet...
i've i've yet to be drawn i've yet i've yet to relapse okay
i am i i've yet to relapse into what past yokey was uh this
time this time will i swear this time uh will be different
guys it's it's guys we're making a progress right now guys
i'm on my way to to recovery.
It's a 50 step program.
It's a 50 step program, guys.
Doug, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's only been two weeks.
And soon, it'll be three weeks.
And then after three weeks, it's gonna be four weeks.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dragunes, I gave you all the gift of basic pattern record
nation you use it well thank you the super chat thank you
thank you okay um but i have noticed that like has been
affecting me in terms of remember when i used to post
schedules on saturday and remember when i used to post
schedules on sunday and remember when i used to post
schedules on monday uh so that like may or may not have been
affecting what the top I've been posting my schedule because
instead of me like, what should I do for this week?
I'm like, I'm going to go play deadlock for five plus hours.
So, so I, I recognize the problem.
Guys, I, I, I, I recognize the problem.
But I know I realize I've been like in a slump right now and
I've been using, I've been coasting a lot lately and I've
been using like video games as a way to like escape from uh
from any responsibility and attempts at work because I I
just why do work when I can feel joy playing I would feel
feel the dopamine from gaming so um so today I was like I I
was I that's why I like okay dokey you gotta oh yeah like
yeah my coping mechanism is making everything worse so so
today i was like okay dokey today's the day you actually
gotta step it up like go back to how do you gotta step it up
yeah stop click ghost yeah not be in your slowness yeah get
your work done in time dokey respond to your stuff put those
projects back on like back on the queue and like snap oh my
gosh what's the word when you when I put it on like when I
put it on the stand sorry my brain is like short circuiting
right now I'm thinking about REM I do not know no no no get
out of my head get out
get out of my head yeah you can't put Take those projects
out of the back burner.
Put it back onto the burner.
What is that word?
I always use that word.
Is it back burner?
Let's see.
Oh, putting it on hold.
Yeah.
I'm putting a lot of projects on hold because I've been
gaming instead.
I...
just i just i just been but like today's day today's the day
i'm gonna try and be more productive and like i'll i'll i'm
gonna reward myself with gaming if i if i i want i'm gonna
put up like i'm trying to set up like a little system for
myself where like if i get x amount of work done um if i uh
get x amount of works done i will reward myself uh with
gaming with deadlock with
so I hope that will help me also I was like thinking like
I'm trying to see what what motivates me to like get all my
schedule um like get all my schedule out on time I was
thinking something like uh uh something like um if I don't
post my schedule at least by Sunday at the end of Sunday
then like I need to punish my like have like a punishment
system going in like being like you're not allowed to play
dead like no that's too much I will never be able to
reinforce that like it's like you're not allowed to play
deadlock like don't keep her you're grounded and I was like
but I have the key to my own door like I'll just open the
door I can't do that to myself uh and you like um i need
like a good punishment reward system like i need to post my
all right if i don't i don't have self-control i
legitimately do not i was like why do that to myself when i
can get my dopamines now like dopamine like serotonin now um
um what should i do what do you think would motivate me to
post my schedules on time on sunday
uh just to make myself more uh like get myself back into
that routine
no no i won't be able to do that you're gonna see me on
deadlock like literally tonight like
i'm an addict i know my pro i know i'm an addict i know i
have a problem
Uh, next seat, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you before that those two months
before that i was i was playing rivals ring now now deadlock
just took its place it was it was an issue it still is an
issue um see pattern recognition is a gift i recognize it
okay dohi what's the next step after recognition i recognize
it uh gordon uh oh Thank you, give us a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, the first step is recognizing it.
I'm just trying to figure out what the second step is.
Guys, I just...
I'm just trying to figure it out, guys.
It's a 50-step program.
I'm trying to remember what the second step is after
recognition.
Matoki, how long you've been on the first...
I'm not...
Whoa, who's keeping count?
No one's keeping count right now.
Nobody is keeping count of how long it's been.
The second step is step one.
Let's see.
I'm going to find something real quick.
Let me give me a sec, guys.
Um...
Bum, bum, bum, bum...
Uh...
Sorry, I need to do something real quick on...
Oh, it's because I had streamer mode on!
It didn't give me the banner being like, Duke, you have
streamer mode on!
Okay, let me search something up real quick, guys.
Uh...
Let's see...
the 40 steps i think step two is it it's a repeat step one
and then step three is to repeat step two which is to repeat
step one and then step four is to repeat step three to
repeat step two and then you repeat step one if i keep
recognizing the problem then i I acknowledge it exists.
I think it's working.
I think...
Okay, please.
I think it's working, guys.
Medi, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Punishment, jingle, jingle, toggle.
Just kidding.
Unless...
Thank you, a super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
i don't know i don't i'm trying to like figure out uh i'm
trying to figure out like what i can do uh to like motivate
myself um i feel like maybe like but then it'll be like sort
but then you guys if i have like make it over because that's
a punishment for me but then like then you guys failed like
because then if it's a punishment for me but it's a reward
for you guys then you'll encourage me to fail you'll be like
i'm a toky you should play another game like because it
worries the motivation guys if you're you're cheering for my
downfall
yes you want cheer for my downfall uh dell thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you real talk on step to consult
have one and even super chat thank you thank you i currently
i'm not i'm currently uh not a therapist uh i'm an issue
with it it's just like um it's just like it's very hard to
like find the right therapist because i you have to like
shop around so you find one that you uh uh that you fuck
with and like um i had a therapist i liked but then like i
think she had to move or something and then after that i
haven't had a consistent therapist just because like just
because like i don't have that I like I haven't found one
that clicked with me for a while and at that point I was
like too busy too at that time and um and and uh and and
it's just I think that's like the hardest part of finding
the right therapist man thank you the super chat thank you
thank you and my schedule is pretty rough too um it's like
work deadlock deadlock deadlock deadlock and in some work
And I don't know how to adjust the schedule right now.
It's like everything is important.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Oh yeah, and also walking, dad.
Sorry, sorry.
Sorry, I love my dog.
And also walking and feeding my dog.
It's like somewhere in there.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like how good it would be.
Despite us.
Oh yeah.
Some people wanted context with the tweet.
Uh, that posted yesterday.
So he was at.
The.
Uh.
He was at the dog park.
Two hours.
Yesterday.
Because there were so many dogs there.
Um.
But he didn't care.
Oh my gosh.
I wish I could show you guys.
the photo but anyone like docs the dog park wait let me say
i can zoom in i'm saying it was pretty funny so he kept he
was stealing this one dog's toys uh because one of the
owners brought a bunch of toys at the park um let's see okay
i'm gonna uh okay this these photos are pretty funny wait i
think i can i can just okay i'm gonna crop it so it's pretty
funny um but there are so many dogs keep showing up so then
i like i couldn't leave because you know you know he's
having fun okay so this is unrelated to that story the tweet
that i tweeted the tweet that i did um but basically one of
the dogs rolled over on his belly and then like because like
he's like eight months old this dog is like eight months old
and he was just like playing around with everybody Like, he
has a lot of energy and everything.
And so the dog rolled onto his belly.
Or, like, rolled his back to show his belly to everybody.
And Dad, by the way, Dad was ignoring all these dogs.
But then when the dog rolled on his back to show his belly,
Dad walked up to the dog and then just started licking his
peepee.
And then-
Like, no other dogs, by the way, no other dogs approached
the eight-month-old dog um and uh it's okay it's it's okay i
shouldn't say that i actually i i stopped myself at least
see i shouldn't make that joke uh my dog's eight years old
uh there might be a problematic age gap there uh
I walked up to the dog and just started licking his pee-pee
and then I'm like is he gay like and then and then and then
I know I should have I know I should have said something I
just I don't know I was like shocked you know I was like um
I was like I was like you know how like those people who
were like they're just frozen like they just don't know what
to do because i was just like what the fuck is what the
there's a word for it um like i i was just i didn't i didn't
do anything and just watched it happen until the other the
owner the other owner was like hey i was stunned like
because i was like i was stunned like and i was just like
what the fuck and then the other I was like, hey, there's
no, and then dad, like, and then, well, he, and then the
other dog, uh, flip back.
I, it was a, I was bystander effect there.
I just let it happen.
I just, I did, I was like, what the fuck am I looking at?
Like, so, um, anyway so yeah that's what happened during the
at the dog park i mean there was a lot of other stuff
happening as well so uh let me see if i can grab uh oh yeah
i sent a photo of uh let's see i'm not i beg your pardon i'm
purely discombobulated you griffin thank you with super chat
thank you thank you let me show you guys okay so this is the
other incident at the at the dog park so uh the same the
same day um so the one of the owners um brought a bunch of
toys at the dog park and dad was stealing all of them like
he was like my boy so he did not care about like all the
other dogs were playing with each other except for like my
dog so he was like he was just stealing the the the eight
month old dog toys because like um she brought like a um the
owner brought a bunch of toys and he just kept stealing them
playing with them himself and then all the other all the
other dogs could do was watch
And he's just like, my toy.
He's like, crazy.
He's like, this is, and he was like ignoring everybody.
Everyone's like, let's play.
Yay, I'm having so much fun.
And then he's like, hey, do you want to play with us too,
sir?
And he's like, my toy.
He's like, fuck off.
That's a renaissance painting right there.
All right, here's another photo.
Here's another.
They all hated me.
All right, here's one more.
And that's not the end of the story, too, by the way.
Let me grab this one.
That's not the end of the story.
Because, uh, all right, here's another photo, too.
Where he learned that.
from here's the other photo it's just like my toy this is my
toy you know it's literally not even not even is um so the
other dogs they conduct concocted a plan so you might be
wondering what plan though wait what do you mean they
concocted a plan so they weren't happy with dad just not
hanging out with them and also hogging all the toys because
those toys were meant to be shared with all the other dogs
so the other dogs were not happy about it they're like
they're like we gotta we gotta do something about this uh uh
this green wiener dog taking for taking all the toys away
from us so
Let me grab a picture real quick.
So they surrounded him.
They surrounded him.
Terry, we're like, we're going to do something about it.
We're going to do something about the old man dad.
And then the eighth month old dog.
He jumped his ass.
Oh my god, Doki, they jumped his ass and all you did was
watch.
And then...
And then the eighth month old dog, because those are his
toys, by the way.
The eighth month old dog, the toys are his.
And he decided to take the lead on.
He's like, don't worry, I can take him.
And then he was like, wait, where is the picture?
oh my gosh where is it i saved it okay he's like i got him
i can take the toy i got this grab it grab it i got this
grab it i got this it takes the great the great toy to be
fair dad was the original heister i i'm distracted Grab the
toy and then Bam He got the toy What a brave boy I'll hold
him Such a Such a brave soul And the other die Wanted me to
And you did it help him.
It wasn't even his story.
What do you want me to do?
Some.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He was the one that stole from them.
He was on the wrong side of history.
It's not my fault.
bad at holding his own is actually free from the ultimate
pro or he had it he had exactly he had it coming he knew
what he got himself into he technically started it like 100%
yeah he had fucking look at what he did he did he didn't
want to play with the other dogs yeah he had it like look at
this that's his fault wasn't even his toy
um you could have helped him um here comes dad with a steel
chair or bone thank you for the super chat acer thank you
thank you i didn't take a video it was just all photos of it
so uh he's kind of aura farming not gonna lie yeah but he
got destroyed by an eight-month-old dog though yeah um what
to to be okay he didn't get destroyed he did hold his own
for a little bit but he was he was beating up a child
technically he was technically he wasn't getting destroyed
by it it was a 2v1 um but he was also The future, he was
like, the future is now, old man.
He's eight years old currently.
He's currently eight years old.
2v1, and he was winning.
But yeah, those were dad adventures.
dad adventures from yesterday what else what else um oh yeah
like i said when you think of something when you think of a
solution um what would you guys want me to i'm trying to
think of something it's like a i guess we're gonna put me in
that all right how about this if what kind of scary game is
there oh i guess silent hill 2 is coming out
Um, what's Silent Hill 2?
What's the new Silent Hill game?
Not, sorry, not Silent Hill 2.
The new Silent Hill game.
Um...
Uh...
Townfall.
Yeah, sorry, not 2.
See, because Townfall starts with a T and 2 starts with a T.
I thought...
I got it mixed up.
Is it not scary enough?
Oh, that sucks.
I don't know.
I mean, the game hasn't really come out yet, so...
Um...
Sorry, sorry, I got a message.
I got a message about something.
I can't say what it is.
I'll talk about it in the members.
I'll talk about... If you remind me...
Guys, if you remind me, I'll talk about it in the members.
Guys.
uh all right what's the no because already played time for
jrp guys okay that's the punishment for all of us next seat
that's you're just punishing the entire class nobody wants
that from me like the entire class gets punished no one
wants that you love yes yes you love jrpgs but i i know for
a fact you will not love jrpgs from me i i know that you
will not love it if it came from me
uh it would be torture for everyone involved alan thank you
for the super chat you know fire okay a schedule by the end
of sunday for at least a month we'll do go with a month
because that's like for i just have we'll go with a month um
i will play a jrpg
you play mass effect to garris romance percentage uh oh see
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um alan
thank you super chat thank you thank you silent hill what
has punishment That's a real punishment.
You can play those games now, too.
They even super chat.
They didn't get so...
It's too late.
We settled with JRPG.
So that's how...
This is our little motivation.
If I do not play...
If I do not put out a schedule...
Uh...
If I don't put out a schedule by the end of Sunday for the
next month...
For the next month...
um we i will play a jrpg um all right agreed guys agreed uh
kiaoku thank you for super chat thank you thank you it's
motivation for me because i don't want to kill my chapel too
i kuka thank you super chat thank you thank you doki doki i
am sick do you have any words of comfort for a poor sick
dragon such as i'll never sacrifice you or i'll never commit
kuka thank you for the super chat thank you thank you kuka
if you and rem are dangling from a cliff and i can only save
one of you guys um i'm gonna use the bathroom real quick
i'll be right back
i'm back guys i'm back let me blow my nose
all right uh
uh minler astrum blazing affiliate pop up forward bite solid
onya alan next Thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Thank you.
Oh, I know it would be torture.
There's a reason I picked Mint's favorite game for you to
play.
Not mine.
But you wanted something we wouldn't like Otter.
So we would encourage you.
Exactly.
That is a good choice.
So you want you want like cheer for me to fail, you know?
So I don't want you guys to try and enable me to fail my
goal to be productive.
A cheer for my downfall.
Shia, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hi, Jokey Bird, it's my birthday.
Though I got six, I couldn't celebrate my birthday.
No, just postpone it and just be like, have your birthday
party or your birthday celebration after you recover.
Thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Shia.
to you.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Uh, Megan, you think it was super chat?
Thank you.
I didn't consent to JRPG.
Well, neither did I, but this is what we're gonna go with.
That's why it's never gonna happen, guys.
It's why it's never gonna happen.
Um, um, let's see.
Jakato, I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Get Doki in on that new fire emblem.
As the pun and financial dokey.
Why are you guys trying to decide a JRPGS if I'm gonna
fucking fail?
You guys don't even you guys don't even believe in me like
how my friends didn't believe that I'll get eternity like
You guys I can't believe why are you guys suggesting games
right now as if it's if it's gonna happen Like why are you
suggesting if it's if you guys don't need to suggest because
it's never gonna happen happen it's gonna stop right there
like you really have no faith in me you're
no i'm getting better i'm getting better this 50 step
program that started six years ago maybe eight years ago um
and i'm on step one right now i started step one uh
um dango thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
you should come petros to kiss pop cd w we've so we've
settled on the punishment it's um it's it's gonna be we
settled on the punishment guys it's gonna be jhar bichi and
we're never gonna have that happen because we're i'm not
gonna fuck it up i'm gonna be on time i'm gonna be on track
guys uh i'm gonna be productive i'm gonna have a routine
going i'm gonna have um what's the word i'm gonna be on
track my life is gonna be on track i'm gonna be on top of
things everyone now have my schedule posted by at least okay
at the latest, sorry, at the latest Sunday, at the end of
Sunday.
11.59.
11.59.99.
That's my deadline.
It's gonna, guys, it's gonna be okay.
We're gonna, we're gonna be on top of it.
I will have the discipline and the self-control and all of
that um anyway i'm gonna try my best uh to like uh just be
more on top of things for this like starting today uh that
goes sorry like thompson's gonna be alaska time too end of
sunday in alaska ramona thank you for super chat thank you
thank you has anyone suggested kingdom hearts yet i'm gonna
super chat as a punishment or like as As like a normal
playthrough.
Thank you, the super chat.
Ramona, thank you, thank you.
Alan, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Unwise, thank you, the super chat.
Just don't mess up.
It's that easy.
I know, it's so simple, guys.
We're gonna make it.
I believe in us.
Yeah, how hard can it be?
Anyway, and also, by the way, I'm so sad to find...
GG, fuck.
ease oh my god songs was stuck in my head the last three
days guys it's it's it's stuck in my and i was so sad
because i thought it was an original song i was like oh my
these guys these these guys are geniuses like the fact that
they were able to come up with it was such a beautiful
amazing song like the next mozart just for me to find out
it's ai i was so sad uh oh i was because like it was
basically a cover song to an ai song and i i was so
disappointed because i thought it was gonna be the new
generation um you should have picked mercy i i thought it
was yes it was originally an ai song and and i was i I
thought it would have been, I thought it was gonna be the
next, the next should have picked Mercy Song.
Maybe I'll be Tracer.
I was like, this, like, I thought the mantle was being
passed down.
Like, this was gonna be the current generation Mercy Song.
And that they get, we had to go through the, I'm already
Tracer.
But at least Gen Z will finally have their own song.
And then it just, I mean, it could still be it.
but it just isn't the same you know it just isn't the same
that when it's fully made by ai it's just not the same it's
not man-made you know there's no soul in it it lacks the
heart yeah there's no soul in the song It like ruined it for
me, but it's still pretty good.
That's the worst part because they covered You know, they
they're still like the people who sang the people made it
viral.
They made a cover version of it But the thing that was I
don't know I don't remember if that was real or someone just
made it up But someone was saying how like oh they claimed
they wrote the lyrics themselves But I don't know if it's
just the internet lying, but everyone knows it's an AI song
apparently it's a AI song made What was it?
Okay, it was really funny uh let's see um that bookmarked it
I think I think someone said that was an AI song made by
someone from Japan um and it's covered by uh it's covered by
um Asian Canadians or Chinese Canadians it made me so sad I
was like everything I know is a lie no because they can't
tell it's AI because they doing a cover the the the version
that went viral is a cover version of it it wasn't it wasn't
even the original ai song so they cut they the cover version
of it so that's why no one knew it was ai
first they apparently they rewrote a little like apparently
they said they rewrote some of the lyrics but the original
song was fully ai like the gg fucking easy part is ai let me
see if i can the AI version.
Because I listen to it too.
AI.
Because I listen to it.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Is it this one?
Play the song!
Oh my God.
She's just talking about it.
But she's not even playing the song.
all right let's see gg easy uh msasuke okay is this one this
is the original one oh it's this one
there this is it's the same song it's there it is this is
this was yeah this is fully ai it's it's it's that song and
i'm like oh my god like they got me they fucking got me like
no no i'm like that grandma or your mom sending you a video
and be like sweetie is this ai like i can't tell and then
it's like some dog holding a fucking machine gun and i'm
like oh sweetie i can't tell if this is ai or not can you
confirm it for me that's me ah they got me they actually got
me this is a cat break dancing oh sweetie this video is so
cool i hope it's not ai i wonder how the cat how they train
the cat to do that how do
I will say the girl performer is really pretty and sure her
like I I think like the oh the GG fucking like that is such
a catchy line why did we not think of that why was that not
man-made and she was so good like the the rap part that she
had I love the performance um when she the performance of
her movements doing the rap part.
And I'm so mad.
How it was right there.
The GG fucking easy.
It's right there.
Why did we not think of that?
Why was that song not man-made?
It's weird.
The line is right there.
Why have we not?
You know what's man-made?
The league song.
I saw it.
at least the league song is man-made homegrown it's
homegrown by league players thank god at least has anyone
heard the league song um it was it was like the day after gg
fucking easy was released um i don't know anything about
league but people were like talking about it let me say i
could find it i had no context about the song but Like,
people liked it.
It was like, leak covers are back.
Alright, where was it?
I think it was this.
This was, like, this was, like, on my algorithm for some
reason.
It was, like, day after GG fucking easy.
I like this tweet.
GG freaking easy daughter, or I'm ganking you, son.
You.
I've read all these fights I'm still ganking you My eyes are
shut But I'm ganking you I'm ganking you Bro my algorithms
cooked guys Oh my god me saying never mind Okay on a dokey
news network on a dokey news network did you guys see I
think it's a I think it's a viral shit I think there's no
way this real so did anyone see the uh maybe I should have a
dokey news network outfit like news center like welcome to
dokey news where I update you on 90% accurate news accuracy
news that dokey's got from twitter.com may not be true
depending on whether or not it gets community noted in the
next three days welcome to doki news network
anyway in doki news network uh it may be in the next 10
minutes um uh anyway uh yeah um for those who didn't do is
not whose algorithm is not cooked as mine.
There was a kid.
Some guy, okay, so some guy found a YouTube channel from
this nine-year-old kid who was uploading Minecraft videos on
YouTube.
Apparently he released a video about how he got caught for
using his dad's business credit card to spend $118,000 on
youtube ads to promote his channel uh and so um so
apparently his dad at work um his work called him into the
office being like what the is this be like why did you spend
118k his dad found out because his worked work found out and
like um and confronted him about it and and then and then so
his son made a video about it where he's like I have a
message from my dad I think and he's like I think I have to
quit YouTube is not good guys and his dad was taught like
you know his dad did like some like a little narration in a
video while it was a Minecraft video play in the background
and then he was just like explaining what's going on he's
like I didn't realize that this is that he used my credit
card to spend all that money and like this is bad he was
like this is bad this is really bad um i'm not sure what's
gonna happen um but uh he's not gonna be making any youtube
videos anymore and then at the end of the dad's uh narration
the kid was like guys i think i'm cooked and then the video
ends and I'm just like there's no there's no way this is
real there's no difference this might lose this job and
everything and the kid literally was like oh guys I'm
definitely cooked and he's like this nine-year-old kid and
I'm just like there's no way and then we apparently
apparently you find out that his dad works in marketing so I
was like there's no way this shit is real you know like his
dad is literally in advertising slash marketing like this
has to be a some fucking viral marketing scheme for like
he's trying to do some viral shit it must it must be staged
like at that point like I would say kudos to the Nadio kid
for being such a good actor
yeah he's an industry plant yeah at that point and you find
out later that it was uh that his dad works in mark like it
has to be marketing there's no fucking way he's that calm
like your dad's losing your job and you're the your dad's
gonna lose his job and you end the video be like guys i'm
definitely cooked guy like what yeah i i hope to god it was
a marketing ploy because oh my I hope to God because I
someone someone should take the internet away from the child
like yeah dad's gonna lose his job and be 120k in debt like
I hope to God this nine-year-old kid is this is not that
this is not real this is not real let me see if I can find
the video uh Oh my god.
Yeah, his name is Mighty Mike Plays.
Uh, he doesn't know he'll keep his job.
Oh my god, that's actually crazy.
That's, this was the original post, by the way.
There's no community note yet, which is the thing that
worries me.
There's no, like, and this is where, this is where he was
like, Guys, I'm definitely good.
Guys, I'm like, what the...
My God, do you have anything?
My God, do you have anything you want to say to your
viewers?
Yes.
Yes, he used his...
He used his dad's company card to buy...
to buy YouTube ads to promote his fucking mind his fucking
not even like PC Minecraft channel his fucking PS his
fucking PS5 Minecraft channel he's not even playing it on
Java he's playing it on the he's streaming and making
Minecraft videos on the PlayStation 5 like Gordon thank you
for the thank you thank you let's be real if you did spend
over a hundred thousand dollars the child would become a
missing person's case thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you next thing thank you the super chat thank you
thank you at least a grandmother realized it might be ai
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh noroico
thank you the super chat thank you thank you okay i suggest
you should do have some positive reinforcements too however
we're on sunday just please don't make it five weeks of
deadlock thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
but that's gonna be a reward for me though that'll be a
reward for me anyway other than that what else do i have i
wrote down all the stuff that was like oh uh oh yeah
apparently the new wolverine game is out you know that makes
sense why they stopped really advertising the wolverine game
at some point made me really sad that insomnia game made a
fucking terrible a terrible ass game because they're usually
pretty they're usually pretty good at making good games um
and they're usually um you know they usually make hit after
hit after hit so they don't make duds you know they don't
really make duds but apparently the new wolverine i'm glad i
was thinking about it i was thinking about like oh should i
like because i do have a playstation 5 that's like oh do i
stream wolverine but because you know it's from i love i
love it and so guys by the way.
Speaking of Insomniac, I'm so mad that I didn't buy the
Spyro skin.
I forgot about the Spyro skin that was going to be in
Fortnite.
That was going to be as a pet and I forgot about it.
I literally, like, I was like three days late, but I got the
Among Us bundle.
At least I have my Among Us backpack.
At least I have that.
But I was so upset that I couldn't get, I didn't get the
Spyro pet for Fortnite.
Anyway, um uh but yeah I was I was a little disappointed
about the Wolverine game being not actually apparently you
can't it's like what's the mixtape it's called mixtape right
apparently the Wolverine game is similar to the mixtape game
where like you don't play the game and you can't even you
can't even die unless apparently in the tutorial you can but
um on the chance to not die in the game some people have hit
the 1% to die in the game but apparently it's just yeah
holding W in quick time events uh and everything so um
that's why I was like oh it sucks that uh it sucks that the
Wolverine game wasn't that great because I know a lot of
people were looking forward to it um and apparently uh yeah
like if you like you just can't lose You can't die in the
game at all.
So it's just quick time events and holding W.
That's basically a new Wolverine game.
If they're not that...
No, that's not true.
In the new...
Not the new one.
In one of the universe.
In...
Actually, multiple universes in the multiverse of Marvel.
Wolverine has died several times.
He has died in Logan.
Guys.
I saw him die in Logan.
Sorry if that's spoiler.
That might or may not be spoiler for the movie.
But he may or may not die in Logan.
Snowy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Before I forget, you got this with getting stream schedules
out every Sunday, Doki.
But you fell full.
No, we already decided.
No, no, no, no, because that's what you want.
In order for this to be a success, punishment where you
cheer me on for being able to stay on track it has to be
something that we both don't want it has to be something
that you won't want to cheer for my downfall and we've
decided it'll be jrpgs you may like j you might like jrpg
there's some people here that might like jrpg but i promise
you i promise you if you are a fan of jrpg you will not be a
fan of me playing jrpgs you would wish it would end you
would wish every stream you wish it would be over like it's
even worse for those who are fans of jrpgs
um gus thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
mention quick time events is giving Since you can't fail
them and you don't make an input, it solves anyway.
Oh, that's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Because, like, Insomniac knows how to make good games, so
I'm under what happened.
Maybe they rushed it.
You know?
I won't be surprised if development was rushed.
Is it...
Wait, who owns Insomniac right now?
Um...
Who owns Insomniac, guys?
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Sony oh yeah they haven't been doing so well lately I heard
about the Kojima shit with Sony and the other stuff yeah
apparently Sony's been meddling a lot with a lot of game
companies recently so I saw the the tweets from Kojima like
even Kojima um had to like talk shit which is very
surprising Concord
came from Sony right yeah
they've been on a downward trend right now jokes on you
you're cute when you suffer affection and next you think of
the super chat thank you thank you i'll make sure to skip
dialogue because if i suffer we all suffer like i'll make
sure to skip very important dialogue
to start thank you for the super chat thank you Thank you.
Also, there was a leak that showed that Sonia was working on
Spyverse multiplayer game that they canceled.
Oh, I mean, I mean, I guess they don't want another Concord,
so now they're scared.
Thank you.
NSD, thank you.
The Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
You playing JRPG is great.
It's like a game's during this playing game.
Thank you.
The Super Chat, thank you.
And I'll make sure to romance no one.
I'm going to...
to make sure i don't even romance anyone jrpg with no
romance wait
next see thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um
they're gonna clip you skipping the dial and asking about
the skip lord yes but i know that's what's gonna piss all of
you off i know that's what's gonna get you i'll be i'll skip
this i'm like oh i wonder i wonder what's I don't understand
why is this game not telling me anything.
Oh my gosh Guys this game is I don't understand why they
won't tell me like what's going on like oh my gosh The
writing is so bad guys like how am I supposed to know about
this thing if they don't even like explain it clearly You
won't even romance a cute yowie couple guys only if I guys
are not we won't be playing a jrpg Roy Kohler.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, guys, guys, this is all hypothetical because it's not
going to happen because I'm not going to fail my challenge.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Honestly, I'd love to see Doki going through fire emblem
blazing through all the nuances of fire emblem plants are
ingrained.
What do you think of a super chat?
you thank you Alan do you super chat thank you thank you
this starting to sound more like a punishment to us than
were you not gonna lie thank you because it's supposed to be
a punishment for both of us it's supposed to be so you won't
want me to lose you won't want me to fail you're trying to
cheer for me to for my victory not for my failures um frozen
thank you for super chat thank you thank you don't forget to
only get the bad ending that gives the game halfway.
Thank you, Mr. Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And now I'm gonna make sure, um, if it's like a, like, um,
good, I'm gonna make sure if it's, like, a good song or,
like, uh, one of, a fan favorite song in the JRPG.
I'll be like, guys, this song fucking sucks.
Let me turn down the music.
Let me,
let me turn down the music.
This song is ass, guys.
I'm gonna turn it down.
It's so distracting.
And then, and then I'll talk over the dialogue and the songs
too.
I, oh, and then, and then I'm going to make sure, I'm going
to find out who's the fan favorite character, and I'll make
sure I won't have her in my party.
I'll make sure the most hated character in here, I'll make
sure to put them in my party.
and most hate i'll be like guys i like this character i
think he's my favorite and i'll give all my buffs i i'm
gonna give all my buffs and and everything on the character
that everyone hates next see thank you the super chat thank
you thank you chicago the way it's so turkey i'm playing a
new fire emblem game it's so they haven't had a new fire
emblem game without siblings that are a little too into
We're a decade or two.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Sniffer, thank you.
Thank you.
How do you have a free copy of Diviny Orange or Digital Sin
for stream, Steam, if you want it?
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
I just know this game.
What is it?
I think you should give it to a Dragoon.
Give it to a lucky Dragoon.
They deserve it more than me.
Before I punish them though with a JRPG before I punish both
of us with a JRPG.
Give them a little gift before I send them to hell.
Fish, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
At this point, we're just planning your schedule.
Angriest, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's five bucks.
Pick Xenoblade, too.
Skip cutscenes, skip dialogue, skip songs.
Make the drag go over and just skip everything.
The track was bleed.
They even super chat, they could think.
And I'll be like, guys, this game is so boring.
Oh, my gosh.
Is he singing?
Is this another song?
Oh, my gosh.
And how do I skip cutscenes, guys?
I'm like, it's so annoying.
This song sounds so bad.
Oh, my gosh.
Like, it feels like they made it with AI or something.
Like, it's like half the game.
We're making progress, at least.
Like, skip a, skip a.
All right.
What are the other news?
That's too far.
Gordon, thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
That's it.
You're getting too much enjoyment out of spite.
Punishment is now done, Master Deer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Gordon, thank you.
Thank you.
I was like, they made three.
Three of these games?
All right.
like clearly
clearly they should have stopped that one um kuka thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you and here rem and i
are hanging out hanging out at cliff's edge we just see if
she will if you will play a jrpg bye now next time on the
next episode of toky bird thank you for super chat thank you
thank you banana think of a super chat thank you thank you
uh i really really love zino blade and i endorsed the
decision to rage bait zino blade defense thank you super
chat benad thank you thank you thank you get all the way to
a really emotional scene and ask who is this character again
after skimming no i'm they're going to get to a scene where
a character dies and i talk over it and
over it i was like who is this person again i but thank god
she's dead she was so annoying
and then i skip it halfway and then i then she's about to
say she or he is about to say something really important or
like one like the most memorable Heartbreaking scenes in the
entire game and I'm and then like and then he opens his
mouth and I skip it and
Yago, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Punisher, you gotta be nice to Minto next collab
no matter what she does Thank you for the super chat She's
just gonna take advantage of that and rage bait me Like how
I'm rage baiting you guys Thank you for the super chat Thank
you, thank you
Yeah, she's like He's like I skip
Gordon, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
You talk big for someone who'll take He'll take five hours
for a tutorial For your 9% of the mechanics Hey, that's not
true I remember I remember we were like 99% of the, I
remember like 85, I remember like 50% of the, of my controls
and Yoni Musha, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
I have to be realistic there.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Doki ends up skipping a major character that didn't like,
they didn't like Steph and doesn't realize they're dead
until end credits scene where they say they're dead.
Thank you, the super chat, Jakarta, thank you, thank you.
So you guys, I remember.
What else is there?
Oh, yeah, on the Joki News Network, they announced a new,
you know how they have a new resident movie coming?
I did not realize Robert Patterson is, like, in everything
right now.
Like, I didn't, I forgot they casted Robert Patterson.
I didn't realize he got casted as Leon.
I was like, oh, shit.
Wait, oh, yeah, he's, yeah, he's like, he's having a
generational run right now, where he's, like, in all the,
all the biggest movies that's coming out the last two years.
Apparently, yeah, he's casted as Leon for the new Resident
Evil movie, and apparently the reviews are out right now
from the early screenings, and people are seeing it's
really, really good.
Yeah, so I hope so.
I hope it's not a lie, but apparently from the early
screenings, people are saying it's the best Resident Evil,
like it's the best movie, Resident Evil movie.
I mean, to be fair, the benchmark for Resident Evil movies
are not that high.
But it's the best, the director's best work so far.
And also, it's the best movie that Columbia Pictures has
ever released.
That's not a high bar.
Yeah, I was going to say, that's not a high bar.
Wait, did I got baited by discussing fish again?
I told you.
all right the robert is it not robert patterson is that that
got baited by fucking it's not robert patterson's not in the
movie god fucking damn it yes i did guys okay apparently i
got that one was wrong i i fell for that one thank god
disgusting fish god i'm joking i i told you guys And Doki
News Network, I get my news.
Okay, the one I didn't fall for was the fact that apparently
it is the best film.
The early screenings.
Rada Pazza is not in there.
I almost believed it.
I almost believed it because I was just like, damn, he's in
everything now.
He's in everything.
So at that point, it felt like it was real.
It felt real in my heart, honestly.
I was just what I wanted to believe I just I wanted to
believe
I told you I get it right 99% of the time the Joki News
Network
uh how do you pronounce your name uh Zoku Zoku Cho is that
how you pronounce it but thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you I really appreciate it.
I can't believe...
99%!
Alright.
Anyway.
Jakarta.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, speaking of Robert Patterson rumors, apparently Kojima
is looking to get him bored for Fizz.
And it's just rumors.
But I can see Kojima.
I mean, Kojima wants everybody in his games.
He wants every famous person in his game.
So I won't be surprised.
I won't be surprised if he does get drafted.
That gets drafted in.
But what is true though, what is true, is that the early
screenings did have high reviews.
So people are seeing that it is the, it is currently the
best work that the director has done from the early
screenings.
So we'll see how it goes.
Fish, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Will you ever do a Twilight Watch line if we can't do
Robert, we can't have Robert Pius?
and Resident Evil.
I'm actually tempted to do a Twilight Watch along because I
think Twilight movies are actually pretty funny.
Ironically pretty funny to watch as a group because some of
the things are actually so ridiculous.
Like the writing is, the writing is pretty, pretty dumb.
If you're not, if you're not like a teenage girl.
Yeah, they're very fun to laugh at.
You're not like you're not a teenager guys
we all like the movie is written by a fucking sexually
repressed mormon woman for those who don't know that
nobody's thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
good night toky have a nice night if you do end up playing
deadlock today remember take breaks have fun and take care
of you so thank you thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you um but yeah thank you yeah thank you for hanging
out with us I hope you had a fun time.
And then you have a super chat.
Thank you.
Why do you even know that?
I've talked about it before.
That's why, like, that's why, like, they didn't, they don't
do anything until they're married.
Then they, okay.
Okay.
And then they're, like, this way.
And then Bella's like, there's also, wow, this, wow, this
sex I've ever had.
It was, like, the only time.
yeah it's like and then he's like after you it's like now
it's now it's not a sin it's like bro like edward's been a
fucking actually a 200 year old virgin because he can't do
it unless he's married which says i'm like bro's a fucking
vampire that's already a sin like i'm pretty sure and like i
don't know about i don't know much about mormonism but
assuming that follow like like like how like uh uh yeah i
was gonna say i'm pretty sure vampires are servants of satan
so lore wise like vampires are ready like a like they're
like the undead so like closely associated with hell and
demons and satan but no no no sex before marriage is a sin
so you can't do edward like like what like what the fuck all
right that's where that's where we draw the line that's no
no no any shades of warmth all right uh do you think of this
Superchat, thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Time for work.
See you on the boss.
Thank you, Superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't...
Don't worry, Bella.
I can't fix him.
Oh, yeah.
And then also...
Everybody... Nobody can...
Oh, yeah.
And then the name is...
Um...
Uh...
The name...
Oh, yeah.
For those who don't know.
Those who don't follow Twilight.
Okay, Twilight.
Bella's child.
What the fuck is her name?
me who's a renez me like and imagine naming your child renez
me or how yeah
i draw the line at sparkly vampires uh what kind of name is
that they combined the name of bella's mother renee renee
and then edward's adoptive mother esme and then uh her
middle name is char i'm really reading this wikipedia her
middle name is carly and it combines their father's name
charlie and carly's left car i don't know i don't yeah so
it's like people i don't know i think people combining names
together is a weird thing because they don't sound good a
lot of them don't even sound that good carlyle or sorry
carlyle so her name is renezmi carly Colin.
Yeah, I was like, what was his last name again?
I'm like, what the fuck was his last name again?
Guys, I know too much about Twilight that I wish I don't.
But like, I wanted to fit in.
I wanted my entire volleyball team read Twilight and love
Twilight.
And I really wanted to fit in.
So I had to research about Twilight, guys.
And I know too much about this book and these movies.
And that...
I know too much about it.
I just wanted to fit in.
Oh, I did not watch the movie.
By the way, I never watched the movies other than the first
movie.
But that was only because Sachi made me watch the first
movie that one time.
That was the first time I've ever watched the movie, by the
way.
You know what movie I did?
watch I watched the parody I watched the uh I watched the
fucking what was vampires suck I that was the only Twilight
like movie I watched I watched vampires suck and then like
that's where I got some of the context of like what the fuck
the movie was gonna look like uh yeah I watched that one i
watched the parody movie um i think yeah i watched the
parody movie and i didn't watch the actual twilight movie
and then um and i watched uh uh i saw clips of it so i saw
the clip of how they inserted a random death scene of like
everybody you love dies just to be like it's all it's john
justin it's all justin vision but they don't tell you that
because apparently it was not even in the book and then the
final movie they killed everyone off and like all the fan
favorites to kill everyone off and everyone was like
apparently for those who were watching theaters people were
screaming crying because it was like all the favorite
characters and nobody expected it and then they they like um
like it was like a bait like a bait and switch and then
they're like oh yeah that's just a vision like is a what if
and we do the final fight
let's see oh yeah so like before I ever watched the Twilight
movies the only thing I knew about the movies was the CGI
behind the scenes of Twilight and then of like Bella petting
or Kristen Stewart petting Jacob's head and then also the
one about the the crazy baby animatronic and then the final
fight in the baseball scene because okay The only good thing
I think Twilight brought to society was Paramore.
Because I actually...
I had the Twilight CD.
Like I had the Twilight soundtrack.
That's the only good thing Twilight gave us.
It's like literally Paramore did the majority of the
soundtrack for Twilight.
And I have the soundtrack of it.
And I love the songs that they did for Twilight.
Like, NLC, think of the Super Chat, think of the thing.
Yeah.
We could always do it.
Halo.
TV show, watch a lot.
No, come on, bro.
No, even I was like, bro, come on.
Like, come on.
Come on.
We're trying to have a good time, bro.
Why you got a hard survive?
Why?
Why do you, bro, why do you, why?
you have the harsh vibe bro like dude don't even joke about
that
it has a series i think it like ended at season one i'm
pretty sure uh ziko cho thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i mean you get to see john halo bang i guess
um you get to you get You get to see John Hale's naked ass.
Wow.
All right, what other stuff from the Tokyo News Network?
Is there anything else?
Um...
Oh, yeah.
I forgot to tell you guys about this.
But also, like, one reason why I've been...
I...
Two shoutouts to my staff.
So, basically, I think...
Like, we also...
There was, like, tweets about it from the other captains
from the Wildcard Club.
But my staff went through, my staff and Wildcard Club staff
went through, for my division, by the way, for, I think I'm
allowed to talk about it, but, because I saw, I saw some
people talking about it.
I saw some of the other captains talking about it on
Twitter.
But there was over 600 applicants for my team.
And people are so talented.
Oh my gosh.
I think like the last time I've ever auditioned for a
anything it was like what like three oh my gosh i don't even
know like four plus years ago three plus years ago i don't
fucking remember how long it's been four or five years ago i
don't remember it but um but the standards and the quality
is so much higher because like obviously i um they helped me
narrow it down to to a hundred i think uh they helped me
narrow it down from 600 to i think i'm around a hundred or
less i think you know i wasn't keeping count and i went
through all the audition videos and then like chose my
favorites um and then you know uh and then uh obviously it's
not like oh i picked these and then they're off the go but
it's obviously like we have to coordinate it with the uh
wildcard club staff as well and then um and then like going
through like uh rounds and stuff because it's not like i
pick and then it's over so there's more stuff to go with
that but i had to go through a lot of the uh i had to go
through all of them and then it was so hard it was so
fucking hard and everything and uh and people are so much
more talented now the standards are a lot higher and um the
standard itself is a lot higher versus like in audition
videos and the quality was insane and no i didn't review all
600 um my staff and Wildcard Club reviewed the 600 and then
it was narrowed down to 100 and then I went through it and
then I picked like uh like I picked a bunch of like personal
favorites through the through that and then we narrowed it
down even more and then obviously it's gonna be like we try
to narrow it down more and more and more until until it's
finalized yeah so it was like so so I just went this week or
last week I don't remember right time time blurs for me guys
I just went through like a hundred videos and watched a
hundred videos and I was just like oh if I apply for
anything I would not get into anything like I don't I don't
think if I if I ever apply with the videos I've done for
like to audition and stuff I would not I would not get into
any company into any agency into any project that requires
me to audition there's no way I there's there's no way I
would get into anything with the videos I've sent because I
was like there's like people are editing stuff and then oh
my gosh people are so talented what the i have a platform
like i'm just like i'm just like oh my god i'm so lucky i
got in before it before that like i got in when the
standards were so low i i'm so lucky right now i get Because
I, my video, oh my god, I told you yes, I made my video
movie maker.
It was literally me, um, me talking to the screen being
like, and I'd be like, yeah, I, I think I should be in this,
in, I should think I, you should accept me because blah,
blah, blah, and then, and it was just clips from my stream.
That's it.
I'm just like, oh, it's like, it's like, it's like, it's
like, you should pick me.
And I'm just like, holy shit.
I, it was my $5 microphone, by the way.
I didn't have a streamer mic.
So I'm surprised I even made it that far.
I'm surprised I'm like, I think if I said that far, video
like during like in 2026 i would never receive any callbacks
from anywhere not even like the smaller agencies i don't if
i was like obviously if i was like you know if i send it as
like me right now dokeybird as like with my my like uh with
like like i guess what's the word with my current uh what's
the word like uh i'm gonna say like okay the word i'm
looking for is like my current uh fuck what's that word uh
brand yeah reputation yeah yeah yeah yeah if i submit as my
current brand slash reputation uh use my cloud then maybe
like even for like small but if i if i was like If I was
like a really small streamer, if I was a really small
streamer, and I submitted a video, my audition tape, that I
made all those years ago, and I submitted 2026, I would not
be, I would not get accepted anywhere.
I won't even, I won't even get like a callback.
I would make it past the first round, the first screening.
I think if I think I think I wouldn't even get past the
filters like she did not put effort in the audition video
filter that shit out it's much more no it's 100% much more
competitive now people are so talented um looking at all
those audition videos I was like Jesus oh my gosh uh and
yeah it was crazy seeing like people are just so talented uh
and uh honestly it was really hard it was really fucking
hard narrowing it like just like trying to narrow that down
um and narrowing it down with hundreds of like 100 videos to
watch shout out to my staff they watched every single video
so if you submitted if anyone has submitted a video for to
audition for my team staff members have watched your video
because they were like we want to give everyone a chance we
want to make sure we watch all videos of it so everyone has
a fair chance um so there wasn't like any filters or
anything that they used they literally watched every single
video to make sure every video even those who are unlisted
uh gets a view um so yeah they went through all of So shout
out to them.
They spent, like, I think, nine plus hours going through all
of them.
But, yeah, like, oh my gosh.
So many talented people.
So many amazing singers, too.
I was so surprised.
I was, like, at all these talented people applying to my
team.
And I was like, my team?
Whoa, like...
Oh my gosh.
Manny, thank you.
Thank you.
They're like, grounded rank for top 500.
Easiest in season zero, but for VTubing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
That's not John Hilo.
That's his bastard cousin, Jimmy Rings.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
I also think, to be fair, I also think...
Everyone wants to be a streamer now.
In the past...
streaming was more like a hobby for a lot of people but i
think like nowadays uh people are like oh i want to make
streaming my career like that's the only thing i want to do
and so like dedicate everything into um we get dedicate
everything to like become a streamer uh because of it uh
it's okay thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um there's like college like the crazy part is like there's
like college courses about trying to become a streamer and
stuff which I think might be a scam it's all about luck you
don't need a college degree to be a fucking streamer like to
learn to be a streamer it's literally just like the
resources is on the internet
all the resources are on the internet you don't need to take
a class for that like
but yeah apparently like everyone wants to be a streamer
everyone I know in Japan, like V-Tubing is now, like, I
remember there was a survey for people being like, oh,
what's your dream job?
And then a lot of, like, a lot of people marked as, like,
V-Tubing slash streaming is, like, their number one dream
job in Japan.
But I think, I think, okay, I've said it before, but I think
my opinion regarding, like, streaming, I think, like, IRL,
streaming is getting a little too much, but that's just my
personal issue with streaming becoming a more sought after
job.
It's just because I think IRL streaming is very disruptive
in terms of like, it depends on like what type of IRL
streaming.
But I think a lot of people going into IRL streaming is they
don't really look at like the safety as well as like the
privacy of others.
Sometimes because some people just want rage bait to rage
bait for content or like annoying like you know sometimes
you know some people don't want to be on on on stream some
people don't want to be on stream so don't want some people
don't want to be on camera um you know sometimes you know
someone wants to do their stuff and then someone is just
like doing irl streaming blocking away or like being too
loud or being a nuisance and stuff like that and i think i
personally think that's uh my issue with a lot of people uh
doing streaming now and like i just don't personally fuck
with how IRL streaming is getting um um getting like bigger
and bigger now and everybody's trying to like become the
next uh big IRL streamer and like trying to uh yeah trying
to make content trying to engagement bait just so they like
want to get the next viral clip from IRL streaming and I saw
like that happening at TwitchCon I saw people like talking
about IRL streaming and um yeah i think that's actually my
personal opinion about it i think that's like the downside
of everyone wanting to be an irl streamer and i don't know i
just think it's like i think it's i don't know i just think
i just think it's a little bit of a nuisance and uh and you
know some people just want to be regular people you know
some people just want to have uh regular people and You
don't want to keep their privacies and stuff.
You just don't want to be on camera.
Let's see.
Zoku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you like my laugh.
And I'm glad you're enjoying the stream so far.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
It's...
Yeah, not everyone consents to be on camera.
Yeah, that's so true.
um so yeah that's what i'm that's that's my thoughts on it i
think it's like not everything has to be content you know
type deal not everything has to be content just enjoy life
also i thought it was really funny i was thinking about the
the dad photos again uh and i wish i did record it because i
realized it looks like a nature documentary like the if i
only took pictures i wish i i wish I did record what was
going on and then like it because it felt like a nature
documentary about like everything unfold unfolding and he's
like now the young male wants to uh wants to take over the
pride but first he has to challenge the uh the alpha male he
circles uh he scouts out the before jumping on here we see
the doxin in his natural habitat
next see thank you the super chat thank you thank you
vtubers are heroes we need to combat irl streamers they
enjoy the privacy and never go outside thank you the super
chat thank you thank you animal planet dad the older man
tries to assert its dominance of the red toy very thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you their public spaces
but there's a difference between recording for safety
evidence and rage baiting people because lol funny yeah i
didn't yeah a lot of people engagement bait too much now um
because you're like engagement baiting people's lives and i
think like that's like yeah that's the issue like if you're
rage people online like it's at least it's like it's online
you know like well just turn off the monitor you know type
deal but it's like you're reaching someone in real life like
like that's that's a bit dangerous kuka thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you um not gonna going to lie the
dad photos look like an ad for a toy and the other dogs are
super jealous thank
all right wait what's that oh my god i've been yapping for
two hours wow guys thank you for hanging out with me today
i'm gonna call it here because i love work to do but i have
fun time hang out with you guys um all right all right
remember remember we're gonna try and post schedules on
sunday the latest at 11 59 wait which is which is the last
time zone
which is at um at 11 59 utc oh are the first wait actually
no are the first which one is the last no that's the first
wait no no no no no no no it's the first on the planet
started new calendar okay which is the last time zone to
celebrate new year's new year's eve
UTC, by the way.
I fucked up.
Not UTC.
Oh, it is.
UTC minus 12.
Who lives there?
And who, what country is it?
The last inhabited time zone to celebrate the New Year's is
American Samoa and New a self-governed island in free
association with New Zealand.
Alright.
UTC minus 11.
There's only two countries up here in that country.
Sorry, two territories that are in that time zone.
All right, I'm joking.
PST.
All right, PST, guys.
I'm joking.
I won't find a loophole on Sunday.
So I'll try and put, I'm going to try.
my best uh so we don't have we both don't have to be
punished uh on sunday the latest uh there'll be a schedule
up i'm gonna be back on track i'm gonna look through i'm
gonna i'm gonna answer messages today i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna be productive i'm gonna be productive and i'm gonna um
i'm gonna make my manager i think my manager i think the
happiest person out of all of this is not even gonna be you
or i guys it's gonna be my manager i think it's like the
manager's like that's like
It's just gonna be for one day and then I'll relapse or some
shit.
I'm gonna, but I'm gonna, I'm going to, I'm gonna do my
best.
I'm gonna do my best to be productive.
Um, starting today.
I need, I need to get out of my slump.
I need to stop coasting.
I just, like I said, I've been like avoiding my work by
playing video games because I love, I just, I don't know, I
have a problem, I have an addiction to rank in general.
It's just rank.
I have an addiction to rank in general.
And I just love seeing numbers go up and everything.
But we'll try our best, guys.
We're going to do our best, guys.
We're going to be on my journey together.
We're going to be back in peak form, everybody.
We're going to be back in peak form, guys.
I believe.
Guys, as long as you believe in me, we can go on this
journey together.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get them around and get that blood flowing.
Stay up for me.
but thank you guys for hanging out with me today i really
appreciate it um i really appreciate it i'm glad i was able
to stream today too even though we had a late schedule um
but oh yes oh yes for members members uh for power of the
members power of the this is the last week for the power
server i'm gonna turn pvp on on the last day um so when we
start the stream pvp will be on so there's gonna oh my god
the server's gonna be fucking lag like crazy wait a minute
um and then But thing is, guys, PVP is going to be on
because, and also, you lose everything if you die.
I'm going to tap that setting on.
I'm going to do it so you lose everything if you die.
It's going to be a real bloodbath.
So you lose all the pals that you have on you if you die.
So, so you got to make sure.
that your favorite pal is it's gonna be the purge we're
gonna have a purge in the pal world server because was it on
thursday's the last day
now we're gonna have a purge guys yeah so i'm just warning
you guys in events uh anyway guys as always everybody say hi
jerry the posh check it out be around to get that blood
flowing and if you for me, head to bed.
Guys, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.